Blue Beetle is a throwback to the
goofier era of superhero movies but
there's still a lot going on at the end
of the film here's everything you need
to know about the ending of Blue Beetle
warning spoilers ahead
one of the main strengths of Blue Beetle
is its pacing unlike a lot of
Blockbusters these days it doesn't
overload viewers with Exposition at the
top the First Act moves pretty slowly to
its benefit with Jaime Reyes returning
home after graduating college and
discovering that his family is in crisis
his father is recovering from a heart
attack the family business has gone
under and they're about to lose their
house Jaime struggles to find a decent
job to help his family financially but
he catches a break when he encounters
Jenny cord niece of cord Industries
leader Victoria cord Victoria is trying
to use an advanced piece of alien
technology known as the Scarab to create
dangerous weapons for private policing
and Military purposes Jenny steals the
Scarab to prevent this and gives it to
Jaime for safe keeping but it doesn't
take long for the artifact to bond with
his body and mind turning him into the
Blue Beetle with the help of Uncle Rudy
Jaime and Jenny sneak into court
Industries battle Victoria's lieutenant
karapaks and steal a key to Jenny's
father's old superhero Lair well the
trio tries to get the Scarab out of
Jaime Victoria sends her soldiers to the
reyes's house to draw him out leading to
his capture aimed the death of his
father undeterred the Reyes family pulls
together and sets out to rescue Jaime
from Victoria's heavily fortified Island
base
the third active Blue Beetle is a
full-blown assault on Victoria cord's
Island Fortress Jenny leaves the Reyes
family back to her father's secret base
where they discover and power up the bug
a large armored scarab-shaped vehicle
capable of flight the bug comes fully
equipped with an arsenal of gadgets and
laser weapons so the whole crew even
Nana gears up to bring Jaime home with
Rudy at the wheel they crash the gates
and start rampaging the bug proves to be
more than a match for Victoria's
Security Forces Jenny and Jaime's sister
Milagro infiltrate the compounds to
plant explosives and cut the power
meanwhile Victoria tries to transfer the
scarabs code from Jaime into karapaks so
that his omac suit can finally reach
full power this process completes but
Jaime escapes and reunites with his
family after the Scarab reboots he
re-enters the compound to save Jenny and
his sister With a Little Help from Nana
and Rudy it all comes down to a
one-on-one duel between Jaime and
karapaks with our hero ultimately coming
out as the Victor at first he wants to
to kill karapaks to avenge his father's
death but the Scarab shows him his
enemy's tragic backstory it reveals how
carapax was taken by Victoria as a Child
Soldier in Guatemala and forced to do
her bidding Jaime lets karapaks live and
he returns the favor by killing Victoria
and destroying the compound he
sacrifices himself to wipe all Omak
research from the planet back home the
family Mourns Alberto and Jenny and
Jaime kiss
one of the more confusing moments during
the ending of Blue Beetle is the cosmic
dream sequence that Jaime has while
strapped into Victoria's device it's
also one of the film's most powerful and
beautiful scenes knocked unconscious by
the toll the procedure takes on him
Jaime awakens in a Technicolor version
of his family home where he's greeted by
his father though Jaime couldn't have
possibly known for sure that his dad was
dead he realizes it here and the two
share a touching goodbye Alberto tells
his son that it's his Destiny to use his
new powers for good as he does the house
is Stripped Away revealing an open void
around them and a giant Avatar of the
Blue Beetle is this dream simply a
hallucination from a man on the brink of
death or is there something more
Supernatural going on at this point the
Scarab is bonded to Jaime's brain which
could have still effect on his
subconscious or maybe there's magic
involved in the comics the scarab's
original Mission of conquering Earth is
layered because it's changed by magical
forces Blue Beetle does spend time
explaining its version of Kaji da the
sentient within the device so a similar
power could still be at Play It's called
the Scarab it was given to my dad when I
was a kid um it's some kind of a world
destroying a weapon though Victoria
court is the main villain of Blue Beetle
carapax is the muscle known as
indestructible man in the comics he's
the one who actually battles Jaime
throughout the movie but by the end of
Blue Beetle carapax has had a change of
heart after Kaji da shows haime
karapak's tragic past he lets him go
Kara packs then overheats his suit
destroying Victoria's entire facility
all of her Omak prototypes and research
her and himself without the Montage of
flashbacks that we get of karapak's life
this twist might feel a bit sudden but
Blue Beetle shows us exactly how much
he's been made to sacrifice while just a
child his home was destroyed and his
mother was killed in a bombing raid
presumably part of the anti-communist
counter-terrorist operations cord
Industries funded in Guatemala he was
made a Child Soldier in Victoria's
private Army and sent to war against his
own people also that she could establish
a local mining operation we see these
mines advertised in one of Victoria's
corporate videos making it clear that
any political agenda was just a ruse for
corporate imperialism his whole life
care packs has been a tool of that
ambition with Victoria slowly replacing
his wounded body with mechanical
augmentations to keep him going it's
implied that these procedures suppressed
karapak's memories but his connection to
the Scarab brings them back his prior
claim that Jaime's love of family is a
weakness is revealed to be a lie he was
forced to tell himself my family that's
what makes me fun though its tone is
often campy and Goofy evoking early 2000
superhero movies like The Sam Raimi
Spider-Man trilogy Blue Beetle also
deals with some serious themes beyond
the core messages about family bravery
and perseverance there's an underlying
condemnation of corporate imperialism
and the privatization of the military
and police it's like Batman stuff
Batman's a fascist carapax his backstory
is a big part of that his past
demonstrates how Global North
governments and corporations have
historically destabilized and decimated
areas of the global South for profit
Victoria claims that her military
operations in Guatemala Were Meant to
stop dangerous terrorist groups but her
company's minds tell the real story this
breed of corporate imperialism is also
visible in Jaime's neighborhood where
houses owned by cord Industries have
their rent raised constantly to push out
the local Latino Community to gentrify
the community private police are a
rising Trend in the U.S and in Blue
Beetle they Patrol and oppress lower
income residents with impunity they
break down doors and intimidate people
with military-grade weapons all with the
mission of extorting them for money
above all blue beetle is a fun
action-adventure movie it doesn't spend
much time zooming in on these larger
social issues but they're there if you
look for them and the end of the movie
is a cathartic bit of Revenge when Nana
guns down a whole platoon of chord
Soldiers with a laser Gatling gun and
shouts down with the imperialist in
Spanish she's speaking for far more than
just herself
it's obvious from the get-go that Blue
Beetle is a film about family Jaime is
the main character but every member of
the Reyes Clan plays a big role without
Rudy they never would have been able to
get a Ted watch from cord Industries
without the guidance of his father Jaime
wouldn't be the hero he becomes and
without the combined efforts of everyone
else he might never have escaped from
Victoria karapax has a great deal of
disdain for Jaime because of his bonds
with his family hello you feel for your
family
of course he proves that to be false
it's a story carapex carries with him to
endure the pain of losing his own family
though he still carries around a picture
of his mother in a locket she used to
wear only after his memories come back
does karapaks fully become himself again
director Angel Manuel Soto has said that
centering the family was important to
him from the start he didn't find it
believable that a Latino superhero could
keep such a big secret from his family
he told den of geek the experience that
we wanted to show was that family is our
superpower to some extent when we're in
trouble the first people we call are our
parents it was about being able to hone
into that and try something new with
Victoria cord presumably blown to
Smithereens at the end of Blue Beetle
Jenny takes over as the new head of cord
Industries it's clear that she intends
to make some major changes starting with
an end to the company's long history of
military weapons development she also
tells the Reyes family that she intends
to give the keys back to the Latino
Community ending the corporate
dictatorship and private policing
practices that Victoria used to oppress
the neighbor hood is this a bit of an
oversimplification of how Corporate
oversight actually works yes the idea of
cord Industries becoming a good tech
company overnight even with all of the
larger implications of its business
feels a bit like a fairy tale ending but
after everything that Jaime and his
family go through maybe that's what they
deserve regardless Jenny will surely be
a big improvement over her aunt by the
end of Blue Beetle Jaime Reyes is a bona
fide hero he's put a stop to an evil
corporate imperialist and prevented her
from crafting dangerous weapons that
could further harm communities like his
by the end of the film it appears Jaime
isn't really trying to hide his new
superhero identity though he doesn't
mean to he activates the scarab's
exoskeleton while chatting with Jenny in
broad daylight in front of his house he
then takes her with him for a little
flight around town since his whole
family knows about the Scarab and he's
clearly not trying to hide it from the
neighbors Jaime might not be a secret
for long most of DC's biggest Heroes
Have secret identities but Jaime appears
to be taking the Tony Stark route
I am Iron Man hopefully Palmera City
welcomes him it's obvious that Jaime can
do a lot of good for his community and
the city at large and with Jenny now
running Court Industries the leading
power in Palmyra is on his side as well
at one point in the movie Rudy compares
the last Blue Beetle Jenny's Father Ted
cord to Superman in Metropolis or The
Flash in Central City Jaime seems
destined to become that sort of
protector for his own hometown
the mid-credit scene at the end of Blue
Beetle reveals that Ted cord may
actually be alive we're shown his
batcave-like secret lair filled with his
old Blue Beetle suits and various
gadgets but no one's Manning the tech
then out of nowhere a message starts to
play over the speakers a staticky voice
declares that he is Ted cord and that
he's still alive he begs whoever
receives the message to tell his
daughter no clear picture of Ted appears
on the screen however leaving the whole
scene mysterious it's pretty clear that
Ted's return is meant to set up a Blue
Beetle sequel but where has he been all
this time why is he only now reaching
out to Jenny and is it actually him or
could it be some kind of ruse it'll take
another Blue Beetle movie to clear it
all up it's definitely fun to imagine
multiple generations of Blue Beetle
teaming up in a sequel Jaime with his
Scarab exoskeleton and Ted with his
Treasure Trove of goofy retro gadgets
director Angel Manuel Soto explained to
den of geek that he didn't want Jaime to
be a Superman level hero by the end of
Blue Beetle instead the story is more
about him accepting the responsibility
that comes with his powers and growing
with his family beside him the director
said I didn't want it to be another
story where 15 minutes in something
happens and 50 minutes later he's
dominating the experience and by the end
he's saving the world he's not going to
save the world yet he doesn't deserve to
yet given the mid-credits Cliffhanger
it's pretty clear that Soto has big
plans should the movie Spawn a sequel
and thankfully Stars sholo Marie duenya
is ready for that possibility telling
Entertainment Weekly I want to do 12
more years of Blue Beetle he confirmed
that he's spoken with DCU heads James
Gunn and Peter Safran about where Jaime
and his family could go in the future as
the larger franchise develops the actor
added my heart is already so fulfilled
with this movie if we do 20 of these
movies and 40 cameos or if it's just
this one what's most exciting to me is
the opportunity for people to see it and
have little kids everywhere saying oh oh
my gosh this guy looks like me I can be
a hero too
Blue Beetle is one of the best DC movies
in years so it's good to know that the
characters will likely be sticking
around for a while it's been a weird
stretch for the studio with the dceu
timeline ending and the DCU kicking off
under James Gunn a lot of fans have been
confused about what characters and story
lines are part of the new universe and
which ones will be left behind some of
those questions still haven't gotten
answers but Gunn himself has confirmed
that Blue Beetle is part of the vision
for the new DCU he said on the podcast
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum in
the first ECU character for sure is Blue
Beetle in the First full DC move DCU
movie is Superman
of a cryptic
suit was official it fits into the new
plan his wording also implies that the
studio isn't yet fully certain of how
many past characters will come back
whatever role Jaime will end up playing
in the future of the franchise director
Angel Manuel Soto is ready for it he
told a total film our first movie The
Way We wanted to do it was always with
the mentality that we wanted to do two
more at least and taking the traditional
3x structure of a story we wanted our
first movie to practically be the First
Act of a saga
[Music]
foreign